[Música]
vamos directo a Chile porque así el
gobierno comenzó el proceso de
empadronamiento de más de 190.000
migrantes irregulares esta medida hace
parte de una nueva política migratoria
del presidente Gabriel borich una medida
que además agiliza la expulsión de
quienes no se acojan al proceso que
según el propio gobierno Busca promover
una migración ordenada segura y regular
y que contribuye al desarrollo de chile
para abordar este tema nos acompaña
desde la capital chilena Santiago
nuestra corresponsal Patricia Luna muy
buenas noches Patricia y bienvenida a
directo a América edición nocturna en
francy 4 en español contanos cómo es
este proceso de empadronamiento Y qué
implica para los migrantes irregulares
se trata de un proceso exclusivamente de
registro que supone entonces exactamente
Buenas noches Santiago pues supone un
proceso que no va a ser un perdonazo ni
un proceso de regularización masiva
según anunció el subsecretario de
interior Manuel monsalve se trata
estrictamente de un registro esto es
saber el nombre completo de las personas
tener sus huellas dactilares también una
fotografía y poder contar con sus
antecedentes Esto va a permitir a las
autoridades chilenas tener una idea
mucho más concreta De cuántos son los
migrantes irregulares que han entrado en
el país en los últimos años por qué
Porque la cifra que se barajaba hasta
ahora oficialmente era de 150.000
personas sin embargo en este proceso más
de 190.000 se han declarado
voluntariamente para registrarse y e
iniciar así un registro concreto que
según incidió monsalve va a traer más
seguridad al país también recordó que el
tema de la política migratoria y en la
migratoria la migración es uno de los
problemas
que más afecta o que más preocupa a los
chilenos en los últimos meses Patricia
esto se enmarca en la denominada nueva
política nacional de migración y
extranjería del gobierno de chile
contanos Cuál es la situación en la
nación Sudamericana respecto de la
migración irregular y que otros aspectos
incluso Este programa además de este
empadronamiento del cual nos estás
hablando
Pues como tú mismo mencionabas incluye
una expulsión más rápida porque se va a
enviar una legislación a la cámara que
permitirá notificar por email o a través
de un correo certificado y no en persona
como hasta ahora a muchas de las
personas a las que se quiere expulsar
según una evolución la ministra del
interior hay 20.000 expulsiones en el
país que no se han podido concretar por
Estos y otros motivos también la
legislación incluirá motivos para
expulsar a los inmigrantes nuevos Como
por ejemplo el haber sido condenado por
violencia intrafamiliar en su país de
origen será una de las causas que puede
hacer que no se admita esta persona o
que sea expulsada esto entre una serie
de medidas que tratan de regularizar
esta migración que como sabemos ha
afectado fuertemente a Chile en los
últimos años a través de la frontera
porosa con Bolivia y Perú y que se ha
logrado descender la cantidad de
personas que ingresan en los últimos
meses con el despli de fuerzas militares
en la frontera en Chile existen 1,4
millones de personas migrantes
regularizadas por el momento lo que es
una cifra bastante alta teniendo en
cuenta que la población chilena abarca
19 millones de personas lo que se trata
con este proceso que primará a
regularizar a partir del 6 de octubre
aquellos que tengan lazos familiares o
vinculaciones laborales con el país
trata de poner un poco de orden y
también establecer normas claras para
todos en un proceso que ha sido bastante
incierto en los últimos años para
también los migrantes